von mehr als 50 reisen von mutmaßlichen
dschihad kämpfer ins ausland seit dem
jahr 2001 spricht der nachrichtendienst
des bundes im moment 16 mutmaßliche
kämpfer seien inzwischen zurückgekehrt
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion im iran und in syrien kämpfen
derzeit also auch schweizer unter der
flagge des sogenannten islamischen
staates und vor kurzem wurde in der
schweiz eine mutmaßliche terrorzelle
ausgehoben
wie kommt es dass sich junge muslime in
der schweiz derart radikalisieren wer
könnte sie davon abhalten
dies ist unser thema heute meine gäste
sind der politikwissenschaftler aus die
spanier er stammt aus syrien lebt seit
15 jahren in bern und der imam und
island theologe bikini er stammt aus
mazedonien und lebt auch seit 15 jahren
in wil im kart und sagt
ja wie lebt es sich im moment als muslim
in der schweiz bei all diesen
nachrichten von extremismus
extremistischem und fanatischen islam
wir möchten wir uns bedanken für die
einladung und dass wir als muslime auch
die gelegenheit haben mal öffentlich zu
äußern und unsere meinungen und ideen
mit ihnen hierzu teilen wir auch mit das
ganze publikum wir sind wirklich erfreut
mal offen mit menschen zu reden und
unsere sicht der dinge auch offen zu
legen
natürlich nicht es ist nicht einfach
dass wir als muslime ständig mal solch
ein zeitungsartikel lesen und solchen
fernsehberichten hören und ähnliches und
noch dazu auch unsere kinder das mit
sehen und unsere bevölkerung das mit
sieht und dann sagt mein lieber gott
oder was sind wir als muslime vor sind
wir als muslime und ähnliches all diese
nachrichten natürlich tun uns nicht gut
dass muslime und
genau deswegen sind wir je aktiver als
es bis heute gegeben hat war an unserer
öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu
öffnen mit den leuten sehr stark zu
reden viel zu reden also in vielen
podiumsdiskussion in vielen gremium im
gremium und das ist ein ziel das wir
seit dem elften september bis heute so
500 verschiedenen diskussionen geführt
haben ich gebe sie für mich ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich für die einladung
wird das programm ich finde das thema
heute sehr aktuell und eine wichtige
thema vor allem für uns als migranten
die in der schweiz leben wie wir uns
geht wie geht unsere migranten ich bin
das thema auch mit dem integration frage
in der schweiz und kriege nicht noch
weiter machen auf eu ebene aber die muss
dann vielleicht nicht richtig dass wir
über die schweiz mehr konzentrieren das
thema beschäftigt mich sehr weil ich
selber aus syrien komme ich auch die
vérité lese dass man auch mal tief in
das thema offen mehr offen diskutieren
kann wo liegt das problem warum wird
eine junge der in der schweiz geboren
oder aufgewachsen
sich indizien wo sind die problematik
liegt an der gemeinde selber wurde
personen für den migranten oder liegt an
die integration behörden oder an an den
migranten mediation behörden für mich
wenn ich so sehe hier die zahlen 50 55
vom ende wenn man hört ist die ängstlich
für eine kleine stadt wie die schweiz
und die frage ist warum wie vor offen
darüber diskutieren als bringt sehr
betroffen bei ihnen beiden hinterfragen
sie sich als muslim täglich
ich bin
selber nicht so
religiös aber ich komme aus einem
islamischen stadt und ich habe auch
meine familie
das beschäftigt mich selbst rehm täglich
und ich lese viel darüber ich folge auch
die nachricht denn was da in unserem
heimatland osten allgemein abgeht wie
wie die leute reagieren die geht es das
für mich ist natürlich das thema das
worden sie hat aus begriff zu erkennen
was heißt das überhaupt
zusammen mit terror was heißt das denn
überhaupt ist terrorist wäre nicht
religion frage überhaupt in zusammenhang
mit den start gehen also unser thema
heute sie sind ja aus syrien sie sehen
jetzt in den letzten jahren mehrfach
wieder hingereist sie haben geholfen
hilfsgüter gebracht ganz konkret was
beschäftigt sie sehr haben sie da etwas
gehört von diesen ausländischen nutzer
schweizer kämpfern doch natürlich mann
ich habe selbst gehört macht nicht nur
schweiz und von verschiedenen ländern
die verschiedene gemeinden zum beispiel
man hört von verschiedenen nationen auch
nicht nur arbeit ich habe auch einen
langen berichts vom österreich das auch
von alban stamme geläutet kann
verschiedene ethnien die auch dorthin
gegangen sind und vor ort
dort hat man auch gehört waren auch in
aleppo im norden von siedlern
flüchtlingslager man hat gehört dass so
viele ausland ausländer sind dort am
gehalt wenn sie als immerhin viel
unterwegs sind sie unterrichten auch
islamischen religionsunterricht sie
haben also an der oberstufe mit vielen
jungen leuten zu tun in ihrer moschee
ist es ein thema sie davon gehört
also einmal weiter dschihadisten ja
einmal um vier betroffen sind natürlich
vor allem als als imam ich bin sehr
betroffen denn grundsätzlich
meine aufgabe ist nicht nur muslime
seien hier leben und arbeiten das ist
alles irgendjemand des gegangen sondern
ich bin auch immer das heißt eine
gewisse verantwortung müssen wir als
imame auch übernehmen und und quasi
damit denken versteckt hinter dieser
erziehung und aber sind sie
radikalisierten muslimen jungen begegnet
eigentlich nicht wenn sie jetzt einmal
unsere moscheen wir sehen so sonst oder
weil sie sind ja auch in dieser union
der albanischen imame in der schweiz der
stellvertreter auch da nicht kein thema
wir werden natürlich wir machen ein
thema davon wir besprechen also ihr
wisst nicht von konnte wählen und
konkreten fällen überhaupt nicht sparen
weil der rutsche reporter und journalist
kurt pelda sagt der recherchierte sehr
intensiv viele personen eben dieser
kämpfer aus der schweiz sehr getroffen
hat die haben hintergrund balkan oft
dann auch nordafrika und meist
muslimischen hintergrund
auch interessant das zuhören aber wie
ich mal auch in den verschiedenen
gremien das angesprochen habe
im prinzip die betroffene jugendliche
die sind dann
interessanterweise bei keine moschee
mitglied die sind interessanterweise bei
keinem imamen bekannt dann wäre die
frage jetzt mal zu analysieren zu zu
recherchieren
wer informiert sie wer beliefert sie mit
material von wo nehmen sie auch genau
auf meinen hinweisen war wenn ein
jugendlicher dann eine bestimmte zukunft
nicht getroffen hat irgendwie
keine perspektive in der schweiz
gefunden hat dann hängt er mal dort und
hier herum und dann plötzlich diese
leute werden in anführungszeichen besser
muslimas die man selbst nicht und gerade
diese diese perspektiven lose
jugendliche dann werden sie plötzlich
radikalisiert aber wo so wie wir wissen
als muslimin den islam und das ist auch
ein appell an allen muslimen den islam
kann man nicht vom internet lernen oder
kann man auch nicht von irgendeinem buch
lernen ist das was genau passiert wir
kommen auf die frage welche rolle die
moschee und moscheevereine spielen oder
kurt pelda ist es vor kurzem gelungen
mit einem radikalen dschihadisten und
islamisten in der schweiz ein längeres
gespräch zu führen der junge mann der
nun anonym auftritt stammt das
mazedonien und lebt seit 15 jahren in
der schweiz
ja wir wollen nicht praktizieren muslime
soll man anfangen wir wollen so muslime
aus der tradition aber
mit der zeit wurde ich halte gläubiger
und dank internet dank peter vogel dann
lernte ich so mein glauben kennen und
ihr seit sieben jahren praktiziere ich
meinen glauben ich gehöre zu sagen
überzeugt dann muslimen also ich kann
ein überzeugter muslim im internet sind
wir muslime eigentlich alle stark
verbunden hier in der schweiz gibt es
keine muslime die wirklich starken den
islam einsetzen oder starke lesen sie
herr vogel ist schon so wie mein vorbild
ist wie ich fühle mich durch kurzer
muslim und ja ich höre ich sehr gern das
zu also vertritt ein wichtigen islam und
weil es nicht wie manche mama die angst
haben den richtigen islam
zu präsentieren weil sie angst haben man
könnte sie verstoßen
dort will seine muslime endlich getan
und hier ist das problem
es war es ist menschlich dass lima sich
unterdrücken lässt
niemanden lässt sich unterdrücken jeder
lässt sich gegen unterdrückung
das problem dort unterwegs als wenn man
den muslimen richtet man sie zum
widerstand widerstand leisten haben wir
titelt man sie nicht als er auf ständige
oder freiheitskämpfer sondern als
terroristen und das ist alles was ich
mich es was mich extrem stört
es war
paradies zu tun mit ala was haben wir
belohnung alles zu tun diese menschen
verkaufen dass dieses für das jenseits
und allah verspricht diesen menschen
eine gewaltige lohn zum beispiel der
prophet mohammed frieden und segen sein
auf ihn hat uns muslimen gelehrt dass
einer stunde im dschihad zu verbringen
besser ist als 70 jahre alle anzubieten
also zu hause alle zuhause anzubieten so
dass die sonne gewalt verloren im
dschihad zu ziehen die schweizer sind
auf vielleicht hier seht ihr geht danach
wieder regen und das ist gerecht dort
sollten die muslime niederlegen regieren
und nicht und nicht die usa hat so viel
einfluss dort und alle regierungen haben
angst usa zu widersprechen die folge nur
ablehnen und das ist nicht unbedingt
richtig mein traum ist dass sich der
rückkehr des kalifats wiedererleben und
wieder diese goldene zeit tanzen das
islam zurückkehren und nicht mehr nicht
mehr ständig diese erniedrigung
anschauen weil die muslime werden
überall als minderwertig angesehen
über alter drückt
ich korrigiere präzisiere kein staat ist
sondern ein sympathisant diese
sogenannten charter also ein radikaler
radikalisierten muslim der er spricht
wie reagieren sie auf diese aussage ich
denke für mich ist das thema dschihad
ich finde es ist nötig dass im islam
auch man ruf nach einer reform
was er sagt natürlich spannend dass man
eine stunde in den start geht dann geht
man in dem paradies dann ist hat wert im
vergleich zu 70 jahren beten dass es
auch die innerliche glauben bei jedem
muslime dass sie in die stadt gehen das
ergibt eine
profitabilität soli da muss man kämpfen
für für gott und für prophet aber was
heißt das wo sind die grenzen das heißt
die ungläubigen töten was da geschieht
dies erst gebiet man sagt ja die sind
iris habe mit islam nichts zu tun aber
von wo haben sie diese ideologie wenn
jemand wenn ich sehe eine aus
tschetschenien eine aus mazedonien eine
aus nordafrika vom ganzen welt sich
zusammen sammeln und in den dschihad zu
diesem start gehen das heißt es gibt es
gibt etwas verstärkt die leute zieht zu
diesem grad und das finde ich eigentlich
die rolle der moscheen und wunder dass
sie richtung liberalisierung gehen eine
liberale ist laut führen und diese
philosophie und ideologie mit kämpfen
gegen ungläubige gegen anderen
religionen zum beispiel das thema ihr
sie denn oder christen im nord in
kurdistan im nordirak oder syrien dass
man dorthin angreift und sagen sie sind
ungläubige entweder wirst du muslim oder
bewusst gewusst und die frauen werden
entführt als kriegsbeute und und
verkauft und da frage ich mich von wo
kommt das das kommt nicht einfach so vom
von nichts sie haben einmal gespielt
aber während der
gesprochen hat der radikalisierte
muslime waren sie sehr betroffen wie
reagieren sie war eigentlich betroffen
für weitere punkten 23 punkten bei ihnen
die zum teil ein falsch interpretiert
oder sowie das wie auch immer einmal
sagte es gibt nur einen imamen der ganze
europa und zwar pierre vogel und das
anderes ist eigentlich sie haben angst
und sowas denn so was und dass er gut
ist ein islamistische prediger in
deutschland er hat konvertiert vom
evangelischen glauben in köln zum islam
genauso jetzt bei seiner aussagen so
dass da eigentlich nur ein imam gibt und
alle anderen sind quasi so die leute die
angst haben zu hause sehen auch wir
haben das geld ist wichtig jetzt total
daneben was er sagt den die die imame
eigentlich pflegen das leben hier das
islamische leben in der schweiz und in
deutschland und in österreich und zwar
seit jahrhunderten sagen wir das mal in
österreich und seit jahrzehnten in der
schweiz und in deutschland und die haben
eigentlich immer zu ihrem besten schweiß
gegeben um diesen menschen gut zu gehen
und diese menschen gut ankommen und ihre
seelischen schwierigkeiten mit
irgendjemanden zu besprechen und die
verbindung zu gott wieder zu finden
deswegen ich würde es nicht einfach ich
werde nicht einverstanden wenn man sagt
dass diese man eigentlich keine rolle
gemacht haben oder ähnliches zweitens
was ich da bemerkt habe dass der junge
mann da eigentlich spricht von dschihad
oder von jährigen deinem kant aber er
hat mir überhaupt gar keinen koranvers
gebracht oder ein hd frau propheten
gebracht dass wir dass man miteinander
analysieren können sondern widerspricht
nur texten was man irgendwo geholt hat
und das sind so das geht nicht so so wie
sie wissen religion und
religionswissenschaft was man eine eine
grundlage dafür haben und muss man eine
exegese dafür haben also muss man schon
das irgendwie erklären können in welchen
zustand war dieser plan werfen warum ist
das gekommen und wie waren die muslime
wie waren die anderen das ganze und dann
eine große enttäuschung bei mir dass man
nach syrien geht das man muslimen tötet
und dass man die anderen muslimen seien
sie auch manche ethisch oder was auch
immer das zu als als ch zu betrachten
oder das mal
freie frauen von dörfern zu holen und
sie zu versklaven sowas dass sie hat
betrachten das ist eine große
beleidigung für den islam und das ist
überhaupt gar kein islam da wäre ich
wirklich wäre ich mit meinen vollen
kräften islam zu bezeichnen frauen zu
versklaven
und sie irgendwo gerade bei
47 geschlagen wird mal schrift besitzern
wurde prophet muhammad eigentlich ein
vertrag mit schrift besitzung
unterschrieben hat schon in seiner
zeiten wurde zweiter kalifornien hat
eigentlich die christen und juden in
seinem gebieten unter schutz genommen
hat und da und sogar denn hier sieht und
sagt der propheten betrachter die
jesuiten sowie ihr die schrift besitzern
betrachtet also wir haben einen klaren
hd der grundsätzlich von jesiden
explizit spricht wenn wir jetzt diesen
brief von 126 muslim gelernten
betrachten würden und analysieren würden
interessanterweise sie reagieren auf
jeden tag von es gruppen von kali- und
schlussendlich wie sie fragenden khalid
al khali wer hat sie von islamischer
seite gewählt wie kann einer eigentlich
so sehr präzisieren jetzt laufend
aussagen dieses der jungen mannes nur
das scheint ja nicht zu stören es gibt
einen brief den sie ansprechen den haben
126 gelehrte weltweit aus dem islam
unterschrieben da distanzieren sich in
aller form von ihr ist es sein
persönlicher brief an al bagdadi also
wenn ihr es für
das scheint aber diese jungen menschen
überhaupt nicht zu kümmern die verbinden
das ganz direkt das kriegshandwerk mit
ihrem verständnis von islam ich denke
wenn ich zum beispiel um rasche
lieferzeiten spreche oder asien oder
immobilien lieferzeiten im 18
jahrhundert
da war auch der gewalt am spitze die die
angriffe bis sich spanien bis überall
ganze welt die sie nicht immer und
überall friedlich gelaufen und diese
vertrag mit zum beispiel mit der süden
und der ungläubigen das war unter
bedienung die müssen dann gelbe zahlen
die müssen bestraft werden wenn sie das
nicht bezahlen dann dann verlieren sie
ihre köpfe das war nicht so einfach eine
lockere sache das war unter bedingungen
entweder bist du muslim gläubig und
fühlst du wie im das system was wir
führen oder bezahlen
was da für sie sagen jetzt eine ganz
freundlich die zeit im achten
jahrhundert in der zeit nach den
propheten also die ausbreitung des
islams mit gewalttätigen mitteln wir da
eigentlich heute einfach wiederholen und
ich ja das ist das ist so und das gesagt
dass man in diesem kalifat geräte und
das erinnert eben dieses große reich das
ist schon mal gab was das zulässig
eigentlich ich muss dann auch zwei
punkten von meinen kollegen reagieren
einmal diesen kran wärst was er vorher
auf arabisch gesprochen hat dass es dann
nicht ein koran wärs denn sie ansprechen
und das mit titan mit damit kann zu
übersetzen zum beispiel oder allahu
akbar salehi sagst du zu sagen wer es
ist mir nicht bekannt
olympique
marseille an bilder die hier haben sie
müssen wir helfen was hier sprechen kann
es nicht fassen er hat eigentlich nur
ein teil von cranberries genommen und
das wort dauer oder wenn uns das wort da
heißt einladung und er hat eigentlich
dann auf deutsch mit kampf übersetzen
was aber sie sprechen jetzt von china
oder in diesem brief den sie erwähnt
haben diese 126
gelehrten das steht der in puncto
dschihad ist im islam ein
verteidigungskrieg er ist ohne die
rechten gründe die rechten ziele und
ohne das rechte benehmen verboten ab mai
wird der jihad auch als krieg bezeichnet
sie hat wird eigentlich wenn wir jetzt
dass die hard betrachten dschihad wenn
sie ans kind lesen übersetzt eigentlich
sowie ein großer islam theologe sogar
und dann sagt sie hat ist im prinzip
kommt von worten gut und heißt
anstrengungen und bemühungen und wege
gottes was ich gerade mit ihnen tue mit
meinem gebrochenen deutsch ist eine art
von jihad das heißt ich bestreben und
bemühe mich meine religion in der
öffentlichkeit zu bringen und die
höchste stufe von dschihad ist eine
selbstverteidigung das bedeutet wenn
leute uns angreifen wir dürfen um sich
verteidigen und das bezeichnen dann die
islam gelernten das was schert ist aber
diese bezahlung von steuern sie wissen
ja vielleicht mal wenn sie islamisch
sprechen wir haben zwei arten von diesem
bezahlung von steuern die leute die die
muslime bekämpft haben und dann haben
eigentlich nicht gesät sind dafür
verloren dann mussten sie eigentlich die
gc-fans
und sie wurden aber nicht angegriffen
oder im zweiten fall die zweite art von
der steuern heißt diese ganz normale
pflichtige steuerpflichtiger
nichtmuslimen im islamischen staat eine
gewissen steuer zu zahlen und das lässt
sich vergleichen mit den steuern die wir
als muslime in der schweiz sagen das
habe ich kein problem damit wenn man
eine kollektiv allgemeine regel hat
steuer bezahlen seien pflicht in jedes
system das gibt es aber dass man noch
zusätzlich etwas bezahlt wann wir weil
ich zum beispiel nicht an islam glaube
in meinem eigenen stadt darum ich rufe
auch das dass man sagt religion und
staat sollte man trennen wenn ich eine
richtige muss lemgo ii gewinnen da muss
ich scharf system holen und sharia
führen ich komme aus syrien wir haben
christian kurden ja sie den azoren so
verschiedene ethnien religionen ist
mieten konfessionen wie kann ihr system
in syrien führen im heutigen im heutigen
tag es ist unmöglich sie können beten
sie können glauben ich habe voller
respekt an alle religionen sie können
beten aber der stadt dann gehört jeder
bürger hat recht über sie gehen ja jetzt
um die schweiz oder guerrilla und nicht
dass die dass das publikum ist ein
eindruck bekommt dass ich die scharia in
syrien einmal irgendwie unterstützung
sowas und dass sie es nicht unterstützen
das ist jetzt eine gelegenheit für
syrien und ähnliches aber ich frage sie
so als bürger von syrien sie sind
muslime und sie haben bis heute
eigentlich neben den christen in syrien
gelebt und war eigentlich bis jetzt ein
zusammenleben möglich aber das ist das
was war nicht durchgeführt sonst haben
wir in 50er jahren die französische
justiz und system als moderne stadt
gefühlt und jetzt nach 2014 kommt es mit
unterstützung so von verschiedenen
länder und kälte das system führen und
das ist unakzeptabel
sei neben bosch auslegung oder sie sagen
da werden alte muster reaktiviert und
sie bieten uns eine wie soll ich sagen
einen reformansatz oder beispielsweise
so wie sie erklärt haben es wird ja oft
von heiligen krieg gesprochen dieses
heilig und krieg das gibt es gar nicht
im islam grundsätzlich nicht aber wir
distanzieren auch von ms gruppe also
nicht dass sie es gruppe für uns richtig
lautet was sie da treiben und machen
gott bewahre den wurzeln der
radikalisierung wir haben diesen jungen
muslim zugehört wie kommt es dass junge
menschen die in europa aufgewachsen sind
sich derart radikalisieren er wird
jeweils werden zwei argumente genannt
einerseits die fehlende integration und
andererseits eben die religiöse
radikalisierung wenn wir mal bei der
integration an falls sie beide sind ja
mustergültige beispiele der integration
ich habe so wenn sie leben seit 15
jahren hier haben sich beruflich
integriert haben familie gegründet und
sie arbeiten als stellvertretender
leiter in einem durchgangszentrum für
asylsuchende in lyss im kanton bern
gleichwohl sagen sie in interviews die
integration läuft nicht gut warum ich
denke da gibt verschiedene sachen die
das thema integration für mich es ist
sehr kompliziert der komplex
erstens erste frage liegt natürlich an
verantwortlichen für die integration
stellen
fehlende kapazitäten und ressourcen für
eine richtige integration programm zu
führen das wäre deutlich in verschiedene
kantone ich habe mich auch mit anderen
kantone beschäftigt so im namen ist
sparmaßnahmen und sparmaßnahmen und da
sage ich immer auch am falschen ort
sparen finde ich integration sehr
wichtig da konnte man viel besser machen
zweitens die die kantonale behörden
sollten das thema ernst nehmen thema
migration und nach nach lösungen suchen
und drittens die gemeinden selber sagen
wir die migranten selbst
so eine immer mehr kann eine große rolle
spielen mit leuten sprechen motivieren
dass sie sich in der gesellschaft
integrieren und bei eine kleine
enttäuschung für eine ausbildung für
eine schule für eine behörde
ich habe selber auch ab also schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht in alltägliches
leben aber das heißt nicht dann die welt
geht runter und ist ende des lebens und
darum ich rufe auch in verschiedenen
moscheen man hört das licht läuft nicht
korrekt in durch einmal korrekt unseriös
da muss man dahin schauen und da ist die
rolle von einem imam der wirklich eine
richtige integration unterstützt und
diese jungen die in der schweiz geboren
oder aufgewachsen
schützen und den richtigen weg zeigen
und nicht zum jihad und dass sie andere
menschen umbringen im namen dass sie
etwas tun für gott und für partys im
moment sind sie ein will seit langem in
einer kleinen moschee am bahngleis im
industriequartier sie wollen eigentlich
in die öffentlichkeit mit diesem bau
seit jahren wird das verhindert in wil
es gab eine initiative besser leben im
wiener süd quartier ohne übermäßiges
verkehrsaufkommen eigentlich ging es
darum dieses projekt für ein islamisches
zentrum dass sie vorantreiben
eben zu realisieren das wurde dann die
initiative vom stadtrat als nichtig
erklärt es wurden beschwerden erhoben
einer ist immer noch hängig sie können
immer noch gar nicht anders geht seit
jahren haben sie den mut noch nicht
verloren
nein wir haben das mut nicht verloren
denn wir haben eigentlich
große aufgaben und diese große aufgaben
können wir leider in kleinen
räumlichkeiten nicht ausführen und
nebstbei wir sind offene transparente
muslimen wir wollen uns zeigen und wir
verstecken uns nicht jetzt ihre gegner
sagen ja eben stadt so großartige
zentren zu bauen die muslime sollen sich
integrieren sie sollen hier bei uns
leben aber sie sollen nicht unter sich
sich treffen und eigene zentren haben
was sagen sie dazu das stimmt ich frage
mal auch unsere gegner und sage ich mal
wenn sie die muslime in wien ansprechen
oder zu irgendeinem ein anlass einladen
wie sprechen sie sie an wenn sie mal
zeitungsartikel schreiben dann lesen
diese muslime oder die seilbahn hat
diesen zeitungsartikel nicht wenn sie
sie ansprechen wollen wie und wo wir
sind gerne mal so zu sagen und
freiwillig wir sind ansprechpartner ganz
offen in ihren sprache und ganz westlich
angezogen und wir sagen leute wir sind
gerne da wir wollen gerne
zusammenarbeiten
und wenn sie dann in wil gerade
nachfragen was für eine leistung bringt
die moscheen will mit
integrationsleistungen trete ich mal
wir sind ein teil der gründung von
integrations kommission der stadt will
wir sind ständig bei diesen
verschiedenen sitzungen da
wir sind immer diesen ansprechpartner
für irgendeinen familienkonflikt oder
und land das heißt aber sie sehen
integration nicht assimilation also
gleich durch bitte an dass niemand mehr
auffällt sondern sich sagen wir wollen
dann schon auch unser gebet und unsere
wurzeln da pflegen natürlich den
assimilation heißt dann eigentlich
anders und dann schon die definition
wird uns dann irgendwann ein anderes und
richtung bringen wir wollen muslime
bleiben aber wir wollen eigentlich auch
unsere kinder schweizer muslime haben
ist das radikalisierungsprozess ion das
ist natürlich eine große
radikalisierungsprozess ion denn diese
junge mann was wir gerade mal im
fernsehen gesehen haben der könnte mir
diesen wörtern nicht so sagen dann wir
stützen uns auf koran und dann würde ich
sagen erklärt es mir ganz genau wo das
im koran steht und so warum kommen die
nicht in die moschee neben der hat
gerade gesagt diese imame sind
eigentlich irgendwie nicht vollständige
imame oder was auch immer so und dann
heißt es jährigen los gibt einen
besseren namen und dann finden wir das
wohl zu finden aber
ich denke das thema ist
jugendwehr mit thema so uns auf die
schweiz konzentrieren ihre frage mich
wie wird dieser junge in der in der
schweiz aufgewachsene motiviert da gibt
es eine eine frage die man nach die
antwort sucht da gibt es ein kraft
irgend etwas versteckt es der diese
junge motivierte junge ist nicht von
alleine so motiviert bis zum tod gehen
zum dschihad im nahen osten oder wo auch
immer das heißt fällt etwas wenn man
nach sucht der mann der schon mehr macht
und schaut was zieht diese junge hier
von seiner ausbildung zu diesem richtung
soeben das spiegel in der neusten
ausgabe schreibt von 500 die aus
deutschland da sind 180 rückkehr
abenteuerlust ist ein thema das kommt
aber dass vorgeschichte aber mangelnde
integration oder was fehlt ich denke ich
denke das thema ist auch so ich sehe
auch so man muss mit dieser jungen vor
allem die rolle der moscheen ich finde
die kunden eine große rolle spielen eben
im positiven sinne dass sie an denn
positive bild auch vom islam als wie
alle anderen religionen die etwas für
die serie für gott wollen sich von
politik absolut trennen wenn man
religion mit politik verbindet wir haben
auch erfahrungen mit muslimbruder die
anderen macht gekommen islam politik für
mich kann keine demokratische system
führen aber es fehlt etwas ich meine sie
haben ja festgestellt irgendwie und in
der umgebung dass wenn die jugendlichen
oberstufe im unterricht sind in
christlichen religionsunterricht dann
sind die muslimischen jugendlichen
einfach nirgends haben sie angefangen
unterricht anzubieten inzwischen des
gläubigen 50% bands und also zwölf
lektion oder so die woche
was war ihr antrieb dass ich gesagt
haben da muss jetzt was gemacht werden
eine sehr gute frage und wir wurden
eigentlich der sache wirklich in die
tiefe gehen und in der wurzeln gehen und
fragen wenn diese junge leute eigentlich
herum treiben und so jährigen währung
beschäftigt allein was tun sie denn wer
mit dem kommen sieben kontakt er sich
sprechen immer wieder die moscheen an
ich kann ihnen wirklich versichern dass
die moscheen vor allem jetzt da die
motion die ich kenne jetzt einmal von
albanischen gebieten aber auch die
anderen kollegen die ich kenne sie
machen wirklich er regiere ihrem guten
arbeit sehr gut das problem ist die
leute die eigentlich uns den moscheen
nicht treffen die gar nicht zum es komme
aber gibt es nach salafistische zentren
die salafistischen bewegung
beziehungsweise wahhabitischen der
artistisch ist grundsätzlich örtliche
haus legen eine sehr strenge inhalte zu
lassen gibt natürlich das gibt natürlich
und das wenn wir das nicht direkt von
der schweiz kennen oder ein bestimmter
gruppierungen auch in der schweiz kennen
da kennen wir vom ausland auch und
grundsätzlich die salafistische bewegung
die ich nicht als terroristische
bewegung bezeichnet sondern wahabitisch
damit salafistisch wäre eigentlich ein
lob für sie also salafistisch ist die
erste generation nach dem tod von
propheten die leute dinge anders gesagt
dass eben oder rassistische beleidigung
und dies schade der islam im prinzip die
schaden den islam im prinzip ist in der
schweiz das natürlich gibt es schon wir
hören dann so da gibt es mal dass und
ähnliches ist im bund ein schüler musste
sich fragen die sind genau diese leute
die den koran ein zu eins weitergeben
und nicht auslegen lassen und das ist
doch halten auch moscheen in der schweiz
also wenn sie jetzt mich so direkt
fragen ich lese und höre auch viel genau
so wie sie vom von zeitungen und
ähnliches aber leuten die wir als
gruppierungen direkt so öffentlich
gekommen sind wir haben sie noch nicht
gesehen denn die ersten die mit den zu
kontaktieren haben zu debattieren haben
sind wir denn auch wir dürfen dann gemäß
ihnen den koran nicht auslegen und das
wäre für uns dann falsch aber diese
gespräche haben gar nicht stattgefunden
sehen wir sie wir sehen sie dann als
gruppierung oder als vertreter von
irgendeiner probieren und irgendwo nicht
wenn schon dann lesen wir mal zum
beispiel bei einem magazin oder beim
nächsten auch die bestimmte bewegung in
der schweiz und ähnlich ist aber dass
wir sie konkret finden und sehen ja ich
denke da fehlt uns schritte konkret
finden das ist eine riesige aufgabe es
gibt diese gruppe natürlich die sind
sehr streng geschlossene gruppen ich
frage auch sie als imam ist mal zum
beispiel eine integrationsstelle
gemeinde gekommen oder irgend eine
verantwortliche vom staat vom schweiz
seite gefragt wie können sie uns helfen
dass wir mal in dieser geschlossenen
gruppen die salafisten oder diese jungen
mal reingehen und und fürs schauen was
dahin überhaupt läuft uns wieder
angesprochen eigentlich von uns will die
müssen gar nicht zu uns kommen denn wir
sind ständig im gespräch mit ihnen wir
sind wir haben eigentlich wöchentliche
und monatliche sitzungen miteinander sei
integration stadt will und wir und die
gemeinde will also wenn wir jetzt von
wil und umgebung sprechen sie haben uns
gar nicht angesprochen denn in unserer
umgebung finden wir wirklich solche
bewegungen durch ihren
religionsunterricht bezahlen sie doch
nicht oder nein sagt das bezahlen sie
auch nicht denn sie sagen das ist eine
eine moschee gelegenheit und das ist
nicht ein staats gelegenheit
ich denke es gibt eine ganz wichtige
punkte die für mich auch für jede
religion sollte ganz klar kommuniziert
werden ich kann beten ich kann meine
freiheit raum nutzen aber da muss ich
auch meine grenze kennen wenn ich
anfange den anderen zu stören und wenn
man jetzt mal ihr argument das hat der
radikalisierung sphärischer peter
neumann wir sind ja bei den gründen
dafür mein vorwurf an die traditionellen
moscheegemeinden wie es nicht dass die
leute das die leute radikalisieren
sondern dass sie es nicht schaffen
angebote für junge menschen zu machen
und sie damit an die moscheen zu binden
die meisten moscheen sind voller alter
männer geprägt wird dort auf türkisch
oder arabisch das ist schlichtweg ein
attraktives angebot für junge leute auf
sinnsuche deshalb wenden sie sich mit
ihren existenziellen problemen in eine
andere richtung und da greifen die
sozialen netzwerke im internet wo sie
auf salafistische prediger wie pierre
vogel stoßen könnte von ihnen seien oder
ja das finde ich ein ganz ganz gute
argument natürlich sagen sie dazu
kompliment also diese ganze gedanken ist
wirklich für komplimente
dass ich dann eure haut die männer
eigentlich nicht jetzt gerade in will da
sprechen wir von einem modell moschee
wirklich ich mag ähnlich wie in anderen
das ist ja ein deutscher
ja ich meine in einer moschee zum
beispiel sagen wir im raum bern oder wo
ich kenne die jungen leuten sagen 14 15
16 in diesem alter die müsste dann
irgendwie eine animation eine programm
die den spaß macht und wenn sie gehen
nur da gibt es not beten dann sie
tendenz negativ die kommen dann mit der
zeit nicht mehr so diese moschee dann
dann die sozialen netzwerke sind sehr
sehr aktiv die die radikalen sind auf
sozialen netzwerken sehr aktive die
gehen nicht in die moschee ist mit
anderen worten ich kann schon sagen die
die mehrheitlich vom jungen jungen
generation die gehen nicht
kenne ich nicht aber in den händen doch
eigentlich das größte problem oder wenn
wir jetzt schon da wo sie herkommen
mazedonien das ist ja ehemaliges
jugoslawien also da war wahrscheinlich
für das religion kein thema dass die
älteren die dann hergekommen sind die
haben eigentlich von religion das
wahrscheinlich nicht so praktiziert
jetzt hier die jüngeren die menschen
eigentlich zwei spielstunden warum wir
jetzt gerade jetzt man bei diesem
beispiel die moscheen will und ich
persönlich nebst in unter richtig
betreut ca 50 bis 55 jugendlichen jugend
erwachsenen diese jugendlichen haben
jährlichen fußballturnier
jährlichen
exkursionen von marokko bis tunesien bis
sarajevo bis deutschland und ähnliches
diese jugendgruppe bietet
nachhilfeunterricht für kleinen kinder
am mittwochabend für den kinder die
deutsch unter und das und ähnliches
nicht verstehen diese jugendlichen
deswegen ich würde sagen ich möchte
nicht viel dann nur von der moscheen
will erzählen dann bei uns findet
wirklich vieles und in sehr recht viele
richtungen statt aber kompliment an den
mann der das man behauptet hat den was
da eigentlich noch zwei zeilen
untergehen sollte heißt warum schaffen
diese moscheen auch in der schweiz nicht
irgendwie neu attraktivitäten für neue
für die jugendlichen zu so zu
ermöglichen
die frauen wäre ein musterbeispiel der
erde so habe ich auch ein mustergültiger
ihm aber das scheint auch kennen sie
noch andere beispiele wo das so läuft
jetzt bei der union zb albanische imamen
in der schweiz wo ich dann als
vize-präsident wirken wir haben schon
pläne reingefahren hinzugefügt wo dann
langsam der anderen moscheen hier auch
mitmachen zum beispiel weeze abend dann
zwischen den vielen diesen moscheen das
heißt die jugendlichen sollen in allen
allgemeinen wissen aber auch im islam
ist sie bringen einmal
ihren denke es um jugendlichen die in
der schweiz aufgewachsen oder geborene
finde es ist ganz wichtig glaubst
zusagen einem eine 17 jährige mädchen
die in der moschee da muss sie mit
kopftuch gehen schwimmen darf sie nicht
bestimmte regeln nach scharia systeme
und islam und mehrheitlich die
jugendliche die in der schweiz
aufgewachsen die kann ich damit leben da
muss man in den moscheen etwas anderes
anbieten aber als immer
eine 17 jährige mädchen frau kommt ohne
kopftuch ist auch nicht akzeptabel das
geht nicht da gibt's schon problematik
die grundlagen die die ganze islam und
sharia system hat ein problem auch mit
jungen generation die in der schweiz
aufgewachsen die können nicht mit diesem
system was im moschee als unterricht und
erklärung gegeben wird vom islam die
können nicht damit leben und akzeptieren
dass es bei ihm offene oder auch so
streng
ich verstehe meinen kollegen gesprächs
kolleg ist eigentlich zum teil nicht
ganz genau und um zu fragen bei welchem
moschee ist der konkret mal wo besucht
so konkret um diese beispiele man uns
mal dazwischen wenn einem leckeren zu
ihnen kommt das thema aktiv gegen morgen
im
öffentlichen schwimmbad was würden sie
sagen das ist bei mir ist ein
schwieriges problem den 107 mädchen
schweizerinnen und schweizern wir auch
musliminnen haben bis heute bei mir eine
matura arbeiten der moschee gemacht
wurde in eine versicherungs arbeit und
ähnliches und all diese mädchen kamen
ohren einen kopftuch in die moschee und
das können wir mit allen möglichen
lebenslagen eine fremde man darf eine
frau gar nicht alleine in einem raum
treffen da muss man so viele frauen vom
arbeits- und lässt sich auch kindern da
wird wenn man uns mal richtige ist und
viele
weitere menschen
in der moschee menschen das system geht
eine fremde mann und sie kennen das ich
denke dass wir jede darf nicht mit eine
fremde frau alleine in einem raum sitzen
das heißt wie viele frauen müssen man
vom aussieht wenn er damit nur sie zu
beruhigen eine moschee waren noch
weitere leute da wo sie mich gefragt
haben wo dann so viele frauen jetzt
haben sie aber fundamentalistische
argumente wieder gegeben obwohl sie
sagen sie sind nicht praktizieren oder
wenn ich meine es gibt eine diskussion
so was will das weder das war ein jahr
lange diskussion über dieses thema und
ankara wie alles islamwissenschaftler
verwaltungsratpräsident hat auch der
vorschläge gemacht die ich auch sehr
komisch gefunden habe und da ist
wirklich in arabischen medien es ist im
heutigen tag ein thema und das würde ich
auch gerne noch dazu an hängen wenn ich
an vor zwei wochen habe ich auf al
jazeera einen
war an gast und der ruft ganz klar und
deutlich von al dschasira arabisch dass
man die ungläubigen töten muss und ist
eine aufgabe der dschihad und dann frage
ich mich wie funktioniert das warum soll
also solche personen überhaupt erlauben
dass so hoffen natürlich dass für
schweizer wenn sie also englisch schauen
das wird ganz anders gesprochen habe ich
es ist schon auch ganz gefährliche
sachen gesagt und erzählt den leuten in
die falsche richtung modelliert haben
sie waren gerade diese person die sie
gesagt haben wir konzentrieren müssen
der schweiz wir beiden sie und ich haben
davon uns klaren deutlich distanziert
das ist nicht menschlich wenn leuten
heute 29 jahre unter darauf berufen
menschen zu töten was ist los mit
unserer manager die frage was wir jetzt
tun können interessiert mich gleich
genau es hat sich eine junge frau im
rheintal das recht erstritten dass sie
in der schule das kopftuch tragen darf
sie hatte support vom islamischen
zentralrat der schweiz ist zeit
wie gefährlich ist eigentlich dieser
organisation
wird
jetzt als union der albanische imamen
wir auch mal fitz förderation
islamischen dachverbände und kios
koordination islamischer organisationen
schweiz wir haben eigentlich mit
islamischen zentralrat grundsätzlich
nichts zusammen und wir hatten ihnen
sehr deutlich gesagt wenn sie weiterhin
noch in dieser art den islam prediger
nein zu 1 und ähnliches sie
repräsentieren uns auf gar keinen fall
im rentenalter muslime in der schweiz
überhaupt überhaupt nicht wenn sie dann
von 2000 oder 2500 mitglieder sprechen
oder sagen wir 2000 mitgliedern da
können sie dann längst nicht von 400.000
muslime sprechen also und wenn wir jetzt
mal viel von fitz sprechen wo wir dann
eigentlich die absolute mehrheit diese
verschiedenen fachverbänden der unteren
unserem dachverband haben oder kinos
nebenbei auch dann dann ist eigentlich
islamische zentralrat gar nichts mehr
vertretbar vielleicht eine sehr wichtige
botschaft auch ein islamischen
zentralrat denn wenn er ab und zu mal
mazedonien besucht oder kosovo besucht
ich würde ihn sehr empfehlen also dem
vertreter von ihm dort sich nicht als
präsident der islamischen gemeinschaft
vorzustellen denn islamische
gemeinschaft ist nicht der islamische
zentralrat und ich höre ab und zu in die
rezession haben es jetzt klargestellt
400.000 muslime in der schweiz und die
anzahl der mitglieder ist vielleicht
nicht ganz klar
2500 2600 haben wir wie gefährlich ist
das ein traum ich denke für mich zum
beispiel jetzt haben wir an ihm bei uns
hat am markt
das macht mir keine angst ist normal ist
religiöse aufzeigen aber wenn ich den
islamischen zentralrat wie sie auftreten
wie sie sprechen
das beängstigt der gesellschaft und mich
auch persönlich kann man auch religion
gebete in einem normalen form auch
machen und nicht provokativ und das
spüre ich bei islamische zentralrat und
ihre kontakte zum beispiel zum gruppen
die in siegen kämpfen das gefällt mir
auch nicht die die sind in direkten
kontakt mit der schau mal anschauen ist
auch ganz klar unter eine terrorgruppe
und mitarbeiter gebunden sind natürlich
alles abstreiten jetzt sitzt hier kein
vertreter nicola branche sagt achim
sonntagsblick beispielsweise vom 28
september diesen jahres zum es die taten
die man da sieht schaden dem islam das
kann man nicht vom islam näher begründen
sie sicher wichtig auch noch zu sagen
weil kein vertreter des zentralrates
hier ist dieses thema nicht weiter
vertiefen die das hat mich einfach ihre
einschätzung interessiert
wie weiter was tun der bundesrat schlägt
ein dringliches bundesgesetz vor wird
jetzt in der wintersession im parlament
behandelt verbot von al kaida weiterhin
unsere neue auch und weiterhin des
islamischen staates ist das hilfreich
ein neues gesetz ich denke für mich das
ganze thema radikalisierung und und
diese gruppen die man bezeichnung angst
terrorgruppen und die die nach im namen
vom gerufen hat und die ungläubige tür
denn es ist eine welt welt thema es ist
diese gruppen bewegen sich punktuell mal
afghanistan mal im algerien was da im
letzten jahren geschehen das war auch
ähnlich was jetzt die sims in syrien und
irak macht bewegt sich für mich ist die
welt sagt kann ich sagen fest den usa zu
diesem thema im heutigen tag sehr spät
reagiert haben als die syrische
revolution angefangen da waren nur die
liberale kräfte die die zivilisten
die eigentlich nach einem modernen
sozialdemokraten staat gerufen haben
fehlende unterstützung für diese
liberale kräfte die welt hat weggeschaut
was das assad regime gemacht hat und
assad regime hat auch solche zellen
unterstützt und ausgestellt von der
politischen situation aber dieses gesetz
zum verbot von islamischen staat und al
kaida in der schweiz das zum ersten
januar dann kommen soll ist das
hilfreich
ich denke nur das ist nicht ganz
hilfreich sollte man mehr darüber
kommunizieren die öffentlichkeit mehr
die die gemeinden ansprechen sagen wir
balkan nordafrikas julian nahen osten
dass man mehr mit leute kommuniziert
über das thema sie wollen alles braucht
mehr als nur ein gesagt was das das
könnte bei gewisse
sicherheitsuntersuchungen helfen aber
das thema total abzuschaffen mit einem
gesetz ich kann kaum dran glauben ich
denke ein gesetz ist gut und sogar dass
muslime haben schon in der sendung 10
vor 10 forciert einem monat noch ich
persönlich auch mal befürwortet nur also
wie sie wissen das wird dann wirklich
nicht alles so mit einem mausklick lösen
sondern wir denken auch das gibt
aufgaben die mal vom staat her
übernommen werden auch mal von uns
muslimen her übernommen werden und zwar
seriös
einmal so ich denke die erbrechtliche
öffentliche anerkennung des islams und
verankerten gesetz verbindet beide
seiten eigentlich zur vorletzten
spaniens der arbeit und dann eigentlich
nimmt beiden seiten quasi so in
verantwortung die große schwierigkeit
dieser welcher islam sollten öffentlich
rechtlich was jetzt fordern anerkannt
werden wir werden eigentlich reden von
den islam in der schweiz ist und wer ist
das eigentlich wie frage die stelle auch
wo ist in welche stadt in ganzen welt
das der richtige islam gibt und geführt
wird wo ich das ja und der schweiz wer
solche öffentlich rechtlich anerkannt
werden ich denke wenn wir vom islam
sprechen dann sprechen wäre
grundsätzlich von schäden von sunniten
und diese dann sparen diesen diesen
unklarheiten bzw streit die sie unter
sich haben dann ist über den sieg hat
dann nicht mit dem islam so zusammen
sondern vielmehr mit politischen
führungen die schon von der zeit vom
propheten stattgefunden haben wir auch
mal die später bis zur heutigen zeit
auch mal mit politik zu tun haben aber
das wäre jetzt mal ein punkt aber dass
es einen geschlossenen verband gibt der
ansprechpartner ist von mir sagt
kantonal ist das denkbar weil das ist ja
das problem wer ist ansprechend dass wir
als muslime in der schweiz in diesem
zusammenhang gut organisiert sind wir
haben eigentlich wer wir sind auch
vertreter dann der rat der religionen im
schweizer lager religion und wir sind
vertreten mit zwei muslimen mit herrn
doktor fischermeister und mit dr
abschafft also das heißt die vertreten
die höchsten dachverbände der muslimin
fids und kios im prinzip die strukturen
mehr oder wenig angegeben aber wenn wir
jetzt mal von den von den umsetzung des
islams beziehungsweise wie wird das
konkret aussehen das ist eine zweite
phase wir sprechen eigentlich einmal von
der anerkennung als erste phase die
beiden so im pflichten in verantwortung
nehmen und sogar dann die muslime müssen
ihren strukturen voll demokratisch
organisierten das ist auch ein großer
vorteil auch für muslimen in diesem
zusammenhang denke ich würde das thema
anderes sagen im bundesverfassung
religionsfreiheit steht ganz klar und
deutlich jeder mensch schweizer in der
schweiz darf seiner region beten machen
wie er will und da muss wenn man auch
separate paket gemacht für ihre religion
als sie wohl lieber religion und staat
klar getrennt das ist finde ich ganz
klar dass das kommt für mich ist es die
beste lösung verfolgen die idee die in
vielen kantonen eben bei den
landeskirchen zb bei einzelnen anderen
religionsgemeinschaften die jüdischen
gemeinschaften realisiert ist eben die
körperschaften des öffentlichen rechtes
was ist denn für sie der grund wollen
sie da an den finanztopf an die steuern
also wenn sie jetzt mal von staat und
religion trennen und das heißt in
kantonen wo dann die religionen
öffentlich anerkannt sind als
gesetzlichen getrennt sind das ist nach
wie vor staat und religion getrennt ich
denke nicht dass dort eigentlich
konstant gang ein
die körperschaften des öffentlichen
rechts das heißt es ist ein arrangement
einer gewissen zusammenarbeit aber es
gibt einzelne container was auch
kritisch sind die sachen so gut getrennt
also in der politik dann mischt sich
gehört eigentlich nicht und was ist der
grund für uns als muslimin denn in
solchen zusammenhängen wie zum beispiel
terror organisationen oder radikalismus
dann kommt eigentlich die ganze last auf
den bestehenden zentren moscheen
unabhängig davon ob sie dann eigentlich
solchen radikalen da in in ihren zentren
haben oder nicht das irgendwie die
kooperation zwischen zentrum zwischen
dem staat ist nicht also die die
transparenz also es ist für uns sehr
wichtig den ersten augenblick denn alle
alle gott bewahre allererster
terrorattacke dann sind wir eigentlich
quasi in große bedrängnis worden dazu
gibt es noch das was der herren damit
ihrem zitat gesprochen hat wenn diese
moscheen eigentlich etwas mehr finanzen
haben dann könnten sie auch mehrere
strukturen und die fr strukturen
aufbauen die für diese neue generationen
auch interessant und attraktiv werden
könnte aber für mich so ein paket sagen
wir eine moschee dann nebendran
geschäfte die auch vom moschee gefügt
werden und dann noch mehrere plätze und
dann mann mann wird auch führen zu einem
geschlossenen
gebiet gemeinde deswegen die agiere ich
für das anders ja und dass das muss man
da aufpassen und die frage ist es läuft
ihn alle moscheen wirklich korrekt und
seriös und transparenz wie man
eigentlich wünscht für die schweiz oder
nicht die lampe die imam-ausbildung das
wird den freiburg in der schweiz ein
studienzentrum islam und gesellschaft
heißt das diskutiert wir sprechen nicht
von imam ausbildung das wäre ja was ich
in deutschland zum teil in österreich
realisiert wird der nächste schritt bei
sowas sinnvoll wird ja stark bekämpft in
freiburg so ein zentrum finden sie das
sinnvoll
wir wollen aus der schweiz eben keine
imame aus saudi arabien
wir wollen in der schweiz keine namen
aus der arabischen welt jetzt gerade mal
das und dann wollen wir wenigstens die
immer mehr wir ausbilden das wäre dann
eigentlich für uns muslimen völlig ok
bzw
den islam kann man in saudi arabien in
tunesien in london im bus sind wir auch
in der schweiz lernen und warum denn
eigentlich nach tunesien werden wir
schon dass die besten ausbildung in der
schweiz haben dann können wir das mal
auch hier organisieren aber dass das was
ich an berichte über london gelesen habe
und auch hat zusammenhang mit diesem
zentrum in freiburg das nicht nachher
der wunsch kommt dass wir auch noch
parallel justiz bei muslim gemeinde noch
führen als schade justiz noch parallel
neben neben dem normalen justiz das muss
man auch da vorsichtig sein und
aufpassen für was fühlt dann der nächste
schritt wir sprechen von einem
studienzentrum islam gesellschaft
vielleicht mal von imam ausbildung
später machen die moscheevereine genug
machen die moscheen genug in der schweiz
gegen die radikalisierung
ich denke sie konnten etwas mehr machen
obwohl ihre anstrengungen anstand
anstregungen groß ist und zu schätzen
ist und dazu zu danken ist aber im
prinzip die muslime sollten
grundsätzlich gegen gewalt deutlich und
klar äußern warum erlassen sie keine
fahrt war die fed vor sind entlassen
wurden von alle stellen und von uns als
die namen in der schweiz das sind wir
das mal im vergleich eine kleinigkeit
wir haben alle eigentlich von so vielen
stellen hier fast etwas von al azhar
universität ist groß und weit zu lesen
da haben sie ja studiert aber es wäre
jedoch ein zeichen wenn alle imame der
schweiz so eine verlassen werden dass
das ist vielleicht sehr wohl möglich und
ich weiß nicht ob dann die lösung wäre
aber wenn wir jetzt mal bei fiz die
distanzierung und die verurteilung lesen
bei chaos das gleiche bei union der
albanischen imamen das gleiche das ist
eigentlich mal eine gewisse
positionierung oder eine gewisse klare
stellungnahme nur es wäre vielleicht mal
auch eine idee dass all diese
verschiedenen gremien einfach zusammen
kommen und dass das deutlich und klar
sagen für seinen sohn ich denke der
rolle schön finde ich sie können noch
mehr machen viel mehr machen
vor allem wenn man hört zum beispiel ich
werde auch viel ich schaffe mit
migranten ich habe es tägliche kontakte
mit der problematik verschiedene länder
und so ich höre oft der sagt hier in der
schweiz darf man dass man stellen das
war eine sachbeschädigung sachen
beschädigen da dies in ungläubige und so
und wenn man sowas hört dann man geht
nach vom wo haben sie gehört dann dann
für visum 1 234 personen dann irgendwo
steckt eine mutter dahinter und der
person glaubt daran welche glauben
wirklich toll finden falls eine alle
grund das okay ich hatte mal so gehört
also die moscheen könnten mehr tun jetzt
wir haben von dschihadisten gesprochen
auch von einzelnen schweizern die dahin
in den krieg nach syrien ihre aktien ich
will doch noch mal betonen wir sprechen
von 400.000 muslimen in der schweiz
sprechen von im moment
bundesnachrichtendienst 56 fällen seit
2001 das macht 0,01 prozent die
sterilisation
wie gefährlich ist die situation zum
schluss und wird die schweiz gewappnet
sein berlin ich möchte den rest von
muslimen begrüßen und das ist
99,9 prozent sowie sie sagen dass sie
eigentlich den islam und den deutlichen
islam klar leben sie sind gut integriert
sie gehen jahren arbeiten nach sie
zahlen ihren steuerpflichten nach und
eigentlich diese muslime sind für uns
eigentlich eine große stadt
ja für wichtig denke ich kann nicht
sagen dass 90 prozent vom muslime haben
sich integriert sonst hätte man diese
diskussionen im medien und die
öffentlichkeit nicht gehabt ich kenne
auch viele muslime die sagen ich schicke
meine kinder nicht motion für eine
arabische unterricht waren man weiß
nicht was wir nebendran verzehr für die
kinder diese vertrauensbasis bei mir
persönlich auch fällt es ist nicht ein
vorwurf ist nicht auch persönlich im
wiener moschee aber allgemein ich fühle
mich nicht wohl mir ist lieber wenn
meine kinder arabisch und tarif bei
einem moschee mehr trotz alles zeigt
oder bei einer integration stelle lernen
reichen die maßnahmen aus
ich denke es ist auch diese ganze thema
ist ist kantonal unterschiedlichen
kanton macht anderes das ist auch das
problem in der schweiz um es in diesem
thema selber aber das thema der sich
selber auch mit dem thema beschäftigen
dass man auch mit kantonalen integration
stellen noch mal diskutieren weil das
wird jetzt wirklich noch mehr kommen in
der schweiz noch was da abgeht zum
beispiel mit i es die diese kämpfe und
die ganzen geschichte muss man zum
schluss noch mal das thema integration
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen
alimi da haben wir für diese ansichten
für dieses gespräch version auch
ihnen danke ich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und verabschiede mich von ihnen